from last week that you had some teams
yes
so in
so you will have to decide
which team
is
different scores
so the first challenge
i will
tell you the name of the ingredients in
italian and you have to find it on the
table
and the article the correct article okay
determinant article
i want the article
love
how about milan
now we have
manderley
so you can get the point i'm in your
team can i help her out
i'm in her team yeah oh okay
i think yes
next word
but you need to put an article okay
is
so what is the fruit alone
okay this is difficult and i will give
it to you also without article because
it's kind of a weird exception
it's really weird
where are they
and we leave them as a
don't chop them this whole
then we have all the other
ingredients
okay
yes
and
okay
while in a separate bowl
you can
mix
miscollate
you can make kind of a hole and buco an
enchantro and you add all the honey
and you try to mix it and that's gonna
be a total mess
and you can use a spatula or you can use
your hands that are
lava you have to wash your hands very
well and again if you have rings an
alley
remove your rings or they will
wish to eat
some
wouldn't be great
okay
um so you will have these two
bowls one with the
farina
and then
and the other one with the sugar and
water
and then
just one part we will add lemon
so we will we can make these different
variations as i told you the traditional
cantuchi or cantuccini
are with mandalay but we will make some
with the
chocolate these are the gold
drops and
and we can also add the
vector to one part
of our
of our dough
so then you will join the dolls all
together
okay and we will i will show you but the
idea
well
we will have to put la carta forno
literally means
okay and then we will make some
some kind of long and wide
uh pieces of dough
and then the stuff will be ready
for the first baking
it will bake for about 20-25 minutes
until it becomes a little golden and
then we will take them out
cut them
and then we will rebate rebate
is to cook
twice
these regular cookies they're not baked
and we call this coffee even like
regular cookies that you cook only once
but what's called
that's good twice
yes
biscotti that is cooked twice but we use
the word biscotti for any sort of
cookies in italian so that's a big
difference like if you go if you go to
italy and you ask for this coffee they
won't buy your fantucci they will ask
you quality scotty why
right which cookies do you want because
there are ten thousand different
sculpted
you